become a cultural icon around the world
a champion who overcame great adversity
we take a closer look at mexican artist
frida kahlo
[Music]
it's a face that's recognizable
worldwide the captivating look in the
eyebrows that turn heads
frida kahlo's image is symbolic of a
strong woman whose self-portraits are
some of mexico's national treasures the
more you study her
the more you realize how
everything about her was symbolic and
for the last few months that symbolism
drew at least a hundred thousand people
to illinois college of dupage in three
months
from around the world in a pandemic all
for a chance to walk along the walls
that line her work overseeing that
collection diana martinez she spent the
last four years studying every piece of
calo she was very bright she read and
wrote in english german
spanish
french
she was very well read i think frida was
so ahead of her time you know in terms
of
of women's rights and
believing in yourself she says freda may
be today's original selfie queen but her
work goes back to the 20s and 30s she
was doing hand-painted selfies in her
most vulnerable moments
and she showed herself
when she miscarried a child she showed
herself
suffering after a surgery that went
wrong she showed her pain
that pain meant 30 surgeries a major
accident at the age of 18 and a battle
with polio as a child it shows stories
of survival and resilience that have
resonated with generations a cultural
icon in her home country and abroad my
bucket list is to really see as many
frida
works as i can i think it's her style
that really draws people to it because
her self portraits are just so like
stunning that it's hard not to be drawn
to them
which is why in chicago's pilsen
community the national museum of mexican
art is prepping for a frida exhibit of
its own next year the public cannot get
enough of frida one of the exhibitions
is traveling from
her home museum casa azul
in mexico city there are photographs
that she collected throughout her life
with so much illinois love for frida
here's a question that many are trying
to answer did frida kahlo ever make a
stop in chicago we suspect that at some
point
before she got to detroit they got off
that train at the major hub known as
chicago and perhaps they spent a night
or two here they loved to travel frida
loved to go visit and go see
so there's no question in my mind that
she made it to chicago but there's no
tangible proof of that though we know
her husband diego rivera painted 27
murals at the detroit art institute back
in 1932 and frida was with him in that
time they struck up a friendship with
dance legend and illinois native
katherine dunham she is like the
grandmother of african dance right
she lived in glen ellen she was born in
glen island the town that is here and
when we figured that huge string out
we're like are you kidding that they
were friends and they met it's those
tiny clues that continue to add on to
the frida kahlo story a mexican icon
transcending generations and borders i
think in this time after the pandemic
and what her country's gone through
she's just a great inspiration to keep
moving forward